[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
joined by harold reynolds former gold
glove winner
and uh major league baseball network
analyst
hr where are you right now
dp i'm hooking you up man i walked over
here to coors field
you see the entrance behind me yeah and
then i'm gonna show it
this is media day okay all lined up it's
gonna be
outdoors for the first time all the
tables all the players will come down
and talk to all
everybody today so that starts i think
in a couple hours
weather is gonna be fine it's gonna be
90. it's been roasting hot so yeah it'd
be good
all right if i gave you shohei ohtani or
the field tonight
if you gave me sohail tiny on the field
or the field in homeland derby
oh he's going to outdo everybody
well combined there's going to be more
home runs but he's going to hit the
longest one
dan i'll tell you when i first went to
angels camp
three years ago and shohei just been
there like two days two or three days
i got there fairly early i get to camp
and i'm like
mike trout some standard titan mike said
mike tell me about show your time
and he grabs me by his shoulder and goes
i've never seen power like this ever
i'm like are you kidding me and justin
upton walks up and he says
harold he hits them on the rocks
one-handed
oh you gotta be kidding me now we're
really seeing it it's unbelievable
yeah i'm always curious about this
question that comes up about
hey would you have him just concentrate
on hitting
or would you just let this play out i
mean they lost him already
for a season due to you know arm injury
with pitching but
how would you how would you play this
out with shohei ohtani if you were joe
madden
i think he joe's the perfect manager i
let it play out
you know and the other thing is we get
caught up in worrying about
how great was bo jackson when we looked
back at him we had him doing football
and baseball that's the amazing story
so if you take away the pitching from
shohei he's just another glorified home
run hitter it's the fact that he's
pitching throwing 100 miles an hour that
makes him an attraction like we've never
seen before so let him keep doing it uh
how is he is a pitcher
great stuff i think too early on they
used too many breaking balls
put him in in trouble the last three or
four games i've watched him pitch
he started attacking with the fastball
and
you know when you're throwing 97-98 and
nobody's ever hit you i remember this
with you darvish i went to udarvis's
first
game when he came over here all the hype
and the spring training
and i don't remember who it was but they
turned around this fastball and hit it
over the monster at 7.
and he started throwing breaking balls
the rest of the game you guys think
they've never had anybody hit that
fastball
yeah so i think that had to happen to
shohei too he's starting to figure it
out now
is there a pitch you can get him out on
because it feels like everybody's got a
hole there's a book on you
after a couple of times through the
league
yeah i think you can go down and out on
him a lot more and you can keep him off
speed with some some breaking
balls um the amazing thing about what
he's doing offensively
is mike trout's out and they keep
pitching to him what are these
knuckleheads doing
i don't get it but also
when i when i want the sound i told
people if i just
showed up and listened to him hit
batting prac
take batting practice like i i that
would
i don't need to see the ball i hear the
ball
and it just sounds different do you
remember a guy
that had that similar sound when the
ball left his bat
is bo jackson you know i sound like the
old buck o'neil
talking about josh gibson babe ruth
and bo jackson it's the only time you
heard those sounds
and i'm telling you another bo jack's
the story for you so we're hitting in
the kingdom
early and now it's bose bono's bow is
full
force he already runs over bosworth he's
around 800 yards for a touchdown to king
domestic the next year he's taking bp
and he's telling me he's already
throwing me out so we became friends
he's telling me
you know switch hitter either you can't
run and you can't switch hit
and he's taking bp he's hit and he turns
around the left side and says bows the
switch
hits one down he hits one into the fifth
deck in the kingdom
now i've been there ten years in seattle
and i only saw five balls go up there
it was ridiculous so that's how i think
of
johannes the only athlete i can think
that we've never come across before is
both
but if he had concentrated on just
baseball if bo jackson had
finished that statement well he'd be in
cooperstown
there's no doubt about it he was just
starting to figure it out
the other thing if you drop bo into this
generation right now where strikeouts
didn't matter
we may not see the broken bat over the
knee but we see some big swings and some
long balls
but also reggie jackson famously you
know he struck out more than anybody
but imagine reggie jackson in today's
baseball world
it was just it's just a different game
it just really is i mean it's like your
favorite sport
like basketball guys shooting threes all
the time imagine
all the great scores of the years pass
those guards like pistol pete and stuff
with the three-point line and if you
said that's the most important
it's just a different time we're playing
in he's harold reynolds the former gold
glove winner
uh gave us one of his gold gloves and
then famously took it back
uh mlb network analyst yeah that still
hurt
because you know what it was such a
crappy trophy that
when when we first got that like we
thought it was gold
and and it was just a glove they spray
painted harold and said here's your gold
glove
if that thing was gold that would have
been spent long time ago
are the astros trying to play the role
of victims
it's so tired dan look you're gonna get
booed
you've been booed i understand if you
have an injury and you're not coming to
the all-star game
i'll give you a pass i understand it but
if if it's what i'm hearing that they're
not coming because they don't want to be
booed
it is one of the tiredest things i've
ever heard in sports
it's not living up to the responsibility
of what you should be and it's
disappointing
to the to the the to the core it's
disappointing if that's the case
well you had el touve when you know hits
the walk off and look he's a wonderful
player and i don't know
what's that somebody's backing up hey i
got
dan patrick huh yeah i don't want you to
get hurt harold hold on one second
hold on what's that see this is damn
patrick he's like
live right now and he said can you stop
the beeping you're messing up the show
see then you got pulled man all right
it is is that the porta potty guy
no actually uh yeah yes actually
appropriately yeah right on cue with
me talking to you i'll be like 30 more
seconds he's not gonna let me talk much
longer
yeah all right yeah i don't want you to
harold reynolds injured by porta potty
is not a good headline for you
so you get everything down here yeah uh
well they're getting ready you know
there's our set for mlb tonight but the
red carpet is going to run through here
dan
as well so they got they're going to
have fans lined up on the side over
there
and over there and the players will walk
straight down here on the red carpet
all the way to the stadium into the
entrance there so
that's why i'm standing hey uh have fun
we'll be watching later today
always great to catch up with you thanks
my friend
harold reynolds